welcome back to another episode of
design patterns we're going to be
looking at the singleton today
and uh let's just jump right into it i
think i've already done most the intro
in the first episode now essentially
with a singleton all you want to do is
make sure there's only a single copy of
your class or object ever and that
nobody creates a bunch of it usually
class all right so let's start out by
updating our cmake stuff we're just
going to make a new folder and while i'm
doing this i'll quickly mention that
you're totally welcome to make pull
requests on the repo if i get something
wrong add your notes add your new
examples make corrections that's all
fine and totally expected and wanted so
leaving comments does help like on the
youtube video but
you never know about youtube comments
but
on github with a pull request it can be
properly vetted and as i stated in the
first episode don't expect me to get
these 100 perfect
um i'm kind of given my interpretation
of them and sometimes i'm wrong about
things it happens but uh that's one of
the great things about just jumping and
doing it is you learn a lot
whether you do it right or wrong you end
up learning something so that's also
kind of the point of these is just to
learn all right so we made a singleton
folder we added the subdirectory for
singleton uh let's also just make this
cmake i'm gonna just uh copy this other
one from factory and paste it in here
and we'll open it and uh make sure
we get this updated we're going to start
out with just a main
and i guess i'll have a probably a
single 10.h that should work
and that'll give us a new executable but
first we got to make these files
and then we should be good to go and
start doing some examples
autocorrect is not helping much today
all right i guess it's because the cmake
needs regenerated or whatever but
essentially
uh we can make a single 10 in quite a
few different ways and this is kind of a
risky pattern as in you don't
necessarily want to use it that much so
if you're using it usually you have like
a really specific reason um often for me
personally i i like to use it for things
that manage other things uh because you
typically only want one manager and you
want it to just kind of be like
automatically created when your program
runs
so it doesn't get created by other
people
and
you might be able to access it and do
stuff with it but you can't just like
create managers a willy nilly and that's
generally how i do it so let's go ahead
and make one and make a little demo all
right i'm going to make this very
generic because i can't think of a great
example off the top of my head but
basically uh we're going to make a class
here
we're going to call it uh i'm just going
to call it manager it's going to be a
generic manager in our case
all right and it's it's basically going
to have uh
it's going to have a function that we
can call like initialize or get i
usually call this initializer get so
let's spell public correctly
so it'll look something maybe like uh
it'll return itself basically so manager
star
let's just call this a nid
and this function is where some magic is
going to happen uh let's make a
make a private area too
so basically we want its own instance to
be controlled by itself but there's
nothing yet stopping other people from
creating this manager so to stop other
people from creating it
there's a couple different ways you can
do this but one of the most simple ways
is to just make the constructor private
that way no one has access to it and if
they try to create it they'll get a
compiler and it just won't work so you
just put the manager down here make it
private
that's it and i actually keep putting
this to my columns at the end of these
headers but it's not required
alright so in here we might just have an
instance and we'll initialize it if
someone calls a net so we'll just go
like manager
star
instance
started out this null pointer oh this
needs all to be static also rather
important
that way it's not recreated anytime they
call it knit so if it's something is
static in c plus plus it only gets
created once and that is uh
kind of nice for single tens it uh you
kind of need to to work with that so
you'll do if instance
so if it's
well we could do it not here uh you can
do it either way depending on how you
want to go out so if not instance which
means um if it is not created then we'll
create one so if it's not null
am i saying that backwards i'm saying it
backwards
uh let's just let's not nod it but
that's a can undermine the statement all
right
so
if the instance exists all we do is
return it well assuming we return it
because this init is going to return it
but maybe we want to call it like get
let's let's go with get i guess you
could do it either this is called the
lazy initialization because it doesn't
get created until somebody actually
calls the git and uses it and if you
call get after it's already initialized
it doesn't do anything but return it so
instance so if it's already created we
return it if it's not created so we'll
do else down here
you don't necessarily actually need this
else because the way i'm doing this i'm
going about this logic
we want to create it so we'll go
instance equals new
manager
and then return
instance so yeah we could make this
logic a little more more simple
but essentially this will
do what you want to do no one else can
create this class
uh when you call get it's gonna
initialize it and return it
and if it's already initialized it'll
just return it and there you go there's
a very lazy initialization let's let's
clean this up a little bit and let's
just do the the not case here
and
the reason this is nice is well it's
less lines of code and at the end we can
just kind of return no matter what so
less return statements just one at the
end typically uh better
and uh there's a very clean way so
it had it holds the variable for the
instance if it's uh if it's not created
and it creates it otherwise this just
gets skipped over because it's already
created so it's fine and it just returns
it and there you go you got a little
singleton manager and we could test this
out by going uh
let's try to make one manager manager
well we could go star manager even now
this is where things get a little
interesting because
this here will be fine because you can
hold references to it
holding a reference to it isn't making a
copy it's just another pointer that
points to the same thing so that's
that's a little different because this
here should compile just fine
why do i not have x success here i don't
know i probably need to just include
something yeah standard live all right
so if we just hit play here oh i'm on
the factory one let's switch this to our
singleton one our little singleton
program all being managed by cmake it's
very nice all right and it works fine no
errors so we could still even go
manager equals
manager
get
now this doesn't quite work because we
don't actually have access to this get
function until we instantiate a manager
which is a bit of conundrum right
so how do you do that well this isn't
quite good enough this function here
also needs to be static in that way we
have access to it without needing to
instantiate the manager just part of how
c plus plus works a little bit there and
you see we've don't we no longer have
squigglies so we can uh yeah we can make
a pointer manager not set it to anything
not initialize it and then we can grab
the pointer to an instance with this get
and also you can even do away with this
entire thing
and just call a function from your
singleton so let's go back to our
singleton real quick because well
let me think about this real quick let's
talk about this real quick so if you do
it this way then you're holding a
pointer so often if you're deep within a
function and your function is going to
use the manager maybe somewhere in it
you'll just
grab a temporary pointer to it and just
that way you only have to do this get
method once because the get is going to
do this whole check thing every time you
know it's a it's a it's a tiny thing
maybe maybe it'll do a lot more if you
once you work it up and you have a
bigger thing going on but the thing is
you don't want to necessarily be
checking if it's instantiated every
single time if you're doing this lazy
initialization way and that and that's
why you would do this that's why you
would make your own pointer and and get
it just once and then continue on with
your function and use it as needed
whenever you need it but there's an even
lazier way to do it that's a little less
efficient but doesn't usually matter too
much and that's what i was about to talk
about just wanted to pre-example that a
little bit and that's where you would uh
just call this get returns the pointer
to it and then you call a function from
within the manager so uh you need some
functions from within the manager so
maybe we're storing something you got to
decide what you're managing what you're
doing and maybe your singleton even does
something else um but let's say we want
to just manage
i don't know let's manage
let's manage some shipments of tea
because that's what i'm drinking lipton
black tea
get yours today link below alright so
very quickly i've just made something
for us to manage and uh yeah of course
you're just going to vary depending on
what you might be managing with the
singleton
but i've just made a
struct
called t and
the t has a cost
some ounces and a quantity or i don't
know i'm just kind of making stuff up
here uh
we'll say number bags or something i
don't know okay well i got some fields
uh let's i'm gonna change something here
we'll just call it strength because you
know t's got different strengths all
right well
uh
obviously this is a terrible example if
it were real t there's like a gazillion
fields you want to fill out of what type
and all that but you know we're just
keeping it very simple because uh we
just want something to manage basically
which is often what managers and
middlemen want they just want something
to manage they don't they don't care if
their jobs useful the hard working
people at the low end do all the the
real stuff management just you know it's
kind of they're kind of like singletons
i'm talking nonsense don't don't take
anything from that all right so let's
include rt
and okay so we just want to add some
public methods here like we could have
void add and uh
we'll take a little t
right there so we can add add some t and
of course it needs to do something and
maybe we have just like privately a
structure of managed t's
so i'm just gonna quickly do i guess a
vector
of
t
uh
and i'll just call it t's all right
now let's include vector
yeah we're gonna need that if we're
using a vector this is uh
and maybe we'll have a remove also
and uh
we'll just also take a t i don't know
this is a bit tricky because they need
like unique identifiers to remove them
or something uh so maybe we need
something like that but i don't want to
get into that that's just getting a
little too complicated at this point i
think oh this this is honestly not the
greatest example but hopefully you're
getting the point that's the main thing
is just to have something to code here
all right so you can call your
manager.get and you can add a new t so
you gotta instantiate one i don't really
have one here so i guess i could just
like create one on the fly and since
this is a struct and things are in order
uh we can just put a cost to strengthen
the quantity uh what if we just put
some ones in there
cost of one strength of
two
quantity of three all right it doesn't
actually like this
because we'd have to create it outside
of here like so
it doesn't really like that either
um
yeah we could put a proper constructor
in there or maybe maybe we'll do it as
like an initializer list but
let's let's uh let's not overwork
ourselves
yeah it should work i don't know why i
don't know
uh but it's it's better if it's very
explicit so you could just you know fill
out your t
cost equals one
not uh strength quantity okay
this would do it like that all right
strength
equals two
all right so now we have some t and we
can add it so maybe we have a function
or something that kind of does that and
uh and then if you want to remove it
well you got to have some remove logic
and you got to have some ad logic so you
go back to your singleton go back to
this function and well let's just keep
this super simple and let's just go push
back on this t
and then it doesn't matter because for
example if we have this within a scope
of its own
kind of like so
obviously this t is going to get
destroyed at the end of the scope but if
we've already added it with the manager
now our manager is going to have a copy
of it in here
since we called that ad
and uh you know maybe we want some
access to this stuff too through the
singleton if we want to you know check
the list manage a little bit the remove
you know we're going to decide is it a
matching tee which one exactly do we
remove yeah and that's going to get a
little tricky so let's skip over that
because for sake of example it's just
it's going to make it too complicated
but uh you're probably getting the point
here so then later
uh we could get it as well so maybe we
have a function that's like let's take a
look here maybe we want to be able to
get it we don't want to be able to mess
with this private vector but maybe we
just want to get access to it so we
could do the same thing we could just
have it return a copy of this list
uh with a uh
like well we already have a get method
so i don't want to redo that one so
maybe we'll just do like a
check i don't know or get uh t list or
something yeah sure get t list that's
fine
and it's just going to return our vector
and this will return a copy of your
vector so you can you know you can look
over it and whatever but it's not
actually gonna if you modify it's not
gonna affect this list so just a way to
give access to your private private
stuff without allowing modification of
it of course we could do const but then
people could use fonts cast and cast
that cost away so
accounts doesn't necessarily even cost
which is a whole other rant of buying i
don't even understand the point of const
it literally does nothing uh when you
can use const cast and just ignore it
anyway
so just like a whole giant thing they've
worked on in the language that doesn't
actually do anything it's kind of funny
if you think about it
maybe there's other points that i don't
know but
just a random rant all right so now we
can call somewhere later in our code
manager
get because we got to get the instance
of the manager and then get t list and
of course this returns something so if
this is returning something you want to
actually make sure
they are uh doing something with it
because there's no point in calling a
get t list if you're not doing anything
with it so you'll probably want to put a
no discard qualifier in front of that to
make sure they're actually saving the
new variable because uh yeah if you just
do this
it returns it but you're not doing
anything with it so with no discard it
should at least throw a compiler error
uh which it doesn't
for some reason but it should
maybe i don't have that on somewhere on
my compiler
but uh essentially what we would want to
do is have
let's save this t list so that we can go
through it
later like for
const auto
these and d-list
i guess you could even put this like
right here but that's probably going to
call this getter a bunch so it'd be
better to just save a copy of it once
i don't know the compiler will probably
figure it out work fine but you could
save it or you could put this whole get
t list right here and skip all that up
to you how you want to do it but this is
just an example so it doesn't matter too
much and then you could say stuff about
it uh let's just include
iostream
and
now we'll we'll just see out some stuff
uh maybe we'll make a count
here real quick
just to have some numbers
thinking how i'm going to do this yeah
count
yeah that's that's just to put numbers
in a list it's it's for nothing else
fancy really so uh actually i'm just
going to call this t
and you know we can format it better
cost
strength
quantity
and a little new line character at the
end and i don't think i messed up
anything too dramatically here but uh
this is a pretty naive implementation i
just want to see if it actually shows
our t as how it goes we got one t in
there there's cost strength quantity and
uh it's not this one it's one from the
manager so we could add a bunch of
different t's or remove them and you
know what to have something to check the
list anytime we want stuff like that
this is of course i'll say once again a
very very naive example because there's
no way to really do anything with these
naturally you probably wouldn't be able
to reduce the quantity and stuff but
this would give a single point of access
to it no one else can make additional
managers
and with something like this you could
very carefully control
an inventory and not worry about people
messing it up because the only way for
them to add and remove from it is for
them to get this single manager instance
and call your very specific functions
and manage it so that way you'd make
your very specific functions and manage
it
and and really battle test them and make
sure there's no possibility of error so
this stuff is great for well in my
opinion just in general retail and
managing
stuff that needs to be very carefully
um taken care of but this this is the
lazy
method and there's kind of a
little bit of an expanded example so you
have an understanding of how to go
forward with it and just a ver a random
thing to manage but uh you know this is
kind of the most simple obvious example
and let's so maybe we'll look at another
one
yeah and now that i'm thinking about
this a little more this is actually
going to have some problems uh if you
already know what it is then awesome
you're ahead of the game but basically
the problem is all right so we're
returning
this instance so that actually gives
people some control over it because they
could just look at the memory and change
the memory it's not exactly easy to do
but it's something that that could be
done so it's more likely that we want to
do it a little differently like yeah we
have this instance within this get
function but we could also put this
instance down here privately
and
essentially do the same thing and it
will work just the same
or it should uh i may have let's see
what we do okay so if you're doing it
this way you're going to need to return
a reference
so a little bit of a different here and
you need this to be
a star so this would essentially do the
same thing let's see if this works
oh we're getting a little bit of
complaining
okay i guess with with if you're doing
it this way then you don't have to
de-reference the pointer since we're
getting a reference to it so it would
just be like so
so
there we go and that that should work
now let's see oh we're still getting a
fatal error and it's because it doesn't
like having this static private uh maybe
if we initialize it it'll be a little
more happy but uh i don't think i just
don't think it likes it
no it doesn't yeah so i guess in this
case we'd probably have to just keep
this uh non-static down here uh and we
just still have a static instance but
it's still you know there's something a
little wonky about this as you can see
not actually 100 sure why this is
complaining but basically i think in
some version of c plus they stopped
allowing you to put static private
members so i think it just doesn't like
having that
privately so i guess in most cases it's
going to make more sense just to have it
here
and you can do it either way you could
do it by returning the pointer
and taking it here or by returning the
reference and making this a pointer
either works fine
but uh you know in some examples i read
people were saying you could put the the
static variable or the static instance
as private but that doesn't seem to be
allowed at least with my compiler so
yours may vary but it's probably best
practice to not have it in the private
so this should generally work pretty
well for just keeping your
lazy initialization going okay
and if you just stick with this you're
probably not going to notice any real
issues uh with the singleton but let's
look at a little more alright i guess
one of the things i should mention about
this is
uh one of the problems with it is it's
uh it's not very
friendly to caching like you get this
global variable um the sure one point at
one point that's good about it is it
doesn't get instantiated unless someone
else someone is actually using it so
that's good but it's a global variable
so it's accessible everywhere and that
means it just exists in memory and if
you're doing a lot of if you have a lot
of these it's going to make things
really inefficient and it's going to be
like basically bad for concurrency so
that's one of the big downsides of these
and often why it's not used but uh
i want to talk about at least one other
thing here
all right and this is good this is not
the greatest for this example but
basically
there's some cool things you can do
within this instantiation that kind of
make it nice sometimes so
you can kind of control what kind of
instance you want
for example if you have compiler
directives you can put them in here
and you can say
different kind of instances you might
want so for linux you might want some
sort of certain thing and for windows
you might want another or something like
that so that is one point is you can
just have one manager but you can put
i'm trying to think of a good example
here
um yeah i guess it would be like 132 do
something
um
but they're all going to be the same in
this case because it's just simple
example but just want to at least point
that out that
you can control how it's created based
on what is compiling it this might make
more sense for like compiling for
whether you're doing it on a phone or
whether you're doing it on i don't know
maybe you're doing something on a game
system so you might want different
variants of like file system stuff and
things like that because often
file system
managers or helpers can be singletons
and sometimes you might want different
kinds of file systems created
based on what your
machine is
so that is something you can do in in
these as well i guess just to point out
we could even make this a little more
simple by getting rid of all this logic
and just putting it right here
and just doing that that saves us some
lines of code because essentially this
only initializes once because it's
static so the very first time we call
this it's going to initialize it and
then just return it and if you call it a
second time and beyond then it's already
initialized so this will get skipped and
it's just going to flat return the
instance so this is a little bit cleaner
of a way to write it if you're doing it
in this way this is typically the way i
do it if i use it it's just the super
clean way or at least i try to so let's
for example just put in some some ifs
here because this is how you would do it
say if
unix
will do an uh little compiler directive
when 32 and that's all we'll support for
now maybe we shot back in here too but
uh you get the point you can chain as
much you want because you have different
ones here and you can see my ide here
actually highlights the one that's
getting used so you could put one of
these for your different uh
possibilities of what it might need to
do based on some compiler directive so
now that's a cool thing you can do
with this uh
instantiation people usually call this
something like instance
rather than get but you know you do what
you want i'm gonna i'm gonna change it
to instance i think that's uh
just gonna be easier to understand
and now you can see of course that these
are redundant uh because they do the
exact same thing
but if they aren't then you should
probably do it also people tend to use
these for loggers sound managers
you know just stuff like that anything
you don't want created multiple times
and it needs to end if you want it to be
globally accessible and this also might
be something you only do in debug if
it's like a logger because when you
actually push out the release you want
it to be super fast and you don't
necessarily need to be logging the
release
that way it's more just a little more
cpu friendly and can run faster
and it's also worth noting that you can
subclass these for example we might have
a very base one that we don't really use
and then we have
one that's like uh
you know i don't know what to name it
but you can have it inherit from it and
it still has
uh most of these functions
and it will still have this instance
that you can get from this one
and uh yeah that's just something you
can do is you can subclass them and kind
of work with that system too
which can come in handy all right i
almost forgot about this one other thing
that you can do and it's basically if
you just want to make sure people only
instantiate one of your class so it's
still a single sin technically but you
kind of give it it's just a different
way of doing it without having to do
this and you can have uh you can have
like a boolean here to say whether it's
initialized or
it instantiate it
and set it to volts to start
so what you can do is uh you can take
this up here uh get rid of this whole
thing and just go like so
and just have like uh instantiated
equals true but you can also say if
instantiated already
you can like throw an error so maybe you
just want to use the cert or something
like that
or assert i guess it would be assert not
instantiated uh i don't have a cert uh
header but with something like this if
the first one will work fine but as soon
as they try to instantiate a second one
it's going to throw an error so you want
to make sure they destruct the first one
uh first by having a destructor be like
instantiated equals
false
so you could do it in this sort of way
as well but the tricky thing about this
is obviously this is going to get
created per class so you need this
outside of it and you probably want to
have yeah we're all in a header here so
this is this is pretty awful looking but
if this were the
object file a cpp and not a header file
it would look something like this
so we have this
this one boolean called instantiated
and we started out as false if they
instantiate it we set it to true and
it's going to crash if they try to
instantiate and it's still true and then
whenever they struck the class it's
going to set it back to false
so that they can instantiate again so
this would be another way that you could
allow people to only create one and of
course you wouldn't have to do this
whole instance thing you would literally
just instantiate one but then again
another thing with this is obviously
this is no longer a static singleton
coffee piece so you would have to take
this and also put it up here globally i
think this one personally looks a little
bit
messier but uh
you can kind of see the point uh because
if they want access to these functions
they're going to instantiate it and this
since this is global they're still
working with the same managed info
same thing here and since it's static up
here there's really no way to access it
otherwise because if you try to access
uh
static these static variables from
outside you you just can't you would
have to do them extern non-static
otherwise but that's a whole nother
thing so that's just another way of
doing it that i thought i'd point out
because you know maybe it's relevant to
some people
but just another way to make sure only
one of your class gets instantiated i
personally don't use this way but i
thought at least mention it here in the
end
and there's probably stuff i'm missing
or leaving out so you know feel free to
uh leave comments make pull requests and
add more uh the only thing i do request
if you make a pull request just leave
some good comments within the code so
people know what they're looking at
because if they watch the video and it's
not mentioned they'll be confused
all right that's it yeah i think i think
that's it i think that's all i'm going
to talk about with this one you probably
get the point the main thing is just
kind of understanding how to do this and
understanding uh what it's good for was
when when it's not good for and if you
have any more examples or comments feel
free to leave a comment
and if you think i really messed
something up you're welcome to make
a pool
and leave some explanations there uh
comments always good so uh that's gonna
be it for this episode huge shout out to
the patrons and on all the people to
help support and make these episodes
possible and i'll see in the next one
peace
[Music]
you